[Music]
most people don't think too much about
changing the world but here we do
right joey
[Music]
here at sender labs in tampa florida we
make the world's most sophisticated
synthetic human tissues and body parts
just take a look at joey here while he
might look like a real boy he's actually
a synthetic cadaver he's made to breathe
bleed and act just like a real human
joey leads an incredibly interesting
life high five joey
all this technology he and his friends
are made of allowed them to replace
cadavers live animals and even human
patients
[Music]
a synthetic human takes about three
weeks to build from start to finish
they're very difficult to build there
are thousands of parts if you just look
at the job of assembling one it's
staggeringly difficult it takes six
specially trained teams to make joey
skeletal skin
muscles
organs
vasculature and final assembly and then
there's our tech crew engineering
electronics and tooling
everything that we make has to be stored
in in water when it's not being used
because it's made you know primarily
water just like uh every every living
thing you know there's always a high
demand for real cadavers the supply is
limited they're getting tougher and
tougher to get and with our synthetic
cadavers what we're really mimicking is
live tissue not not in dead tissue so
the experience you get is more like the
experience you would get with a live
body than a dead body
sender technology is definitely
improving the way people study medicine
study medical procedures study medical
device development because it makes the
whole system better allows surgeons to
train in procedures that they would not
be able to train in without risking a
patient
while we'll never know how joey spends
his time after we go home and turn the
lights off we do know that once he moves
into his forever home he'll be training
people to save lives
attaboy joey
you